good morning everybody good morning
ladies and gentlemen thank you all very
much listen I don't want to I don't want
to tempt fate because clearly lots of
results are still coming in and we're
still only dealing with projections but
at this stage it does look as though
this one nation Conservative government
has been given a powerful new mandate to
get grexit done and not just you get
brexit done but to unite this country
and to take it forward
and to focus on the priorities of the
British people and above all on the NHS
and yes we will recruit 50 thousand more
nurses and 6,000 more jeebies and we
will build 40 new hospitals and I am
proud to say that one of them across the
country and one of those hospitals will
be right here in Uxbridge and South
riesling and I am grateful I'm grateful
once again to the people of expedience
house Ruislip for returning me to serve
you it is an absolute privilege to do
this job and to work for you and I thank
once again the police the council
everybody who's worked so hard all night
to count for us the returning officers I
thank my fellow candidates in all their
glory lord Buckethead and others Elmo
and others forgive me if I if I don't if
I don't identify them all but I bubble
I want to thank I want to thank the
people of this country for turning out
to vote in a December election that we
didn't want to call but which I think
has turned out to be a historic election
that gives us now in this new government
the chance to respect the democratic
will of the British people to change
this country for the better and to
unleash the potential of the entire
people of this country and that is what
we will now do and if we are lucky
enough to be returned as the polls as
the exit polls seem to suggest then that
work will begin tomorrow thank you all
very much
or tomorrow today thank you thank you
all very much thank you
[Applause]
well the Prime Minister there returned
in Uxbridge and as you heard they're
rather cheekily perhaps they're staying
with those campaign pledges